who turned you into this guy did
something to America and my mother you
know I was born in the Soviet Union I
didn't come up with much so adversity
America my mom and my dad because when I
was 14 and started working my dad's
liquor store for 2 bucks an hour I was
so full of [ __ ] and he sucked it out of
me over 10 years because he hates lying
and [ __ ] and so he scared me I was
scared to embellish let alone lie I
don't get upset when people like you
know this guy's full of [ __ ] yeah
because I'm like I understand I actually
had that in me but my dad systematically
took it out and I think it comes from
lack of entitlement I turned 14 and by
being the oldest son in an immigrant
family my dad dragged me into the store
small store in Springfield New Jersey
shoppers discount liquors I went from
making $2,000 a weekend looking cool to
the ladies with all my cash to being
paid two bucks an hour to bag ice and my
dad's liquor store for ten hours a day
and more importantly I wasn't allowed to
leave the basement I was truly like
sloth from Hades you know I was like hey
you've got terrible hated it used to cry
going to work for the first year and a
half
finally when I was like 16 my dad let me
leave the basement so I went upstairs to
dust bottles and in 1998 I took over to
the family business and from 1998 to
2005 I grew the revenue of Wine Library
from a three to a sixty million dollar a
year business I had a burning desire to
pay back my parents for being the best I
was passionate like just obsessed with
building my family business for them
because they had put me on so much
emotionally not you know people always
say you know when people like the resume
they're like easy for you to say you
were given a liquor store I wasn't
I built a business for my family and
left with no economics because emotion
my parents perfectly parented me which
has now been the foundation of all my
success there's only one way for to win
a family business radical candor and you
know how easy that is in a family
business almost impossible so I'm giving
you advice that's hard radical candor
you're just gonna lose it's gonna eat
you inside and I've good news for you
this is the only chance to have a good
relationship with them not the other way
around you think you're doing the right
thing to have a good relationship with
them you're leading through things
that's gonna make you have regrets and
real issues with them and you're gonna
snap and you guys are never bad second
third generation family business people
pay the biggest tax in the world and
when they're [ __ ] talented they
really are [ __ ]
you know what family business dynamics
are good for users that's when you're
lucky when you suck [ __ ] and you're the
one benefiting you know when family
businesses suck when you're a winner and
you're paying a tax nobody's ever paid
in life it wasn't about how many
impressions you got or how many awards
you want and [ __ ] can it was about if
we didn't sell [ __ ] Pinot Noir we
weren't gonna eat right so it was
results-driven
my dad and I for all the things we
agreed on all the things we disagreed on
thank God we loved each other just
enough more than we love the business
which allowed us to keep a relationship
but 99% of our energy was always about
the business for the long term you know
it's easy for everybody from the outside
saying yo bro stop carrying your sister
and your uncle and everybody's gettin
money off your back
if it makes you feel good and you're
okay with 15 cents in a dollar or 50
cents of dollar well then that's your
life so I would say this if you've got a
problem with it and your friends are
saying that because they're supporting
what you're saying after four beers
that's one thing but if they're just
observing from the outside and they're
starting to change your mind
I wouldn't let outside sources tell you
what to do with inside a family dynamic
at the end of the day if you are the
parent in the situation of a family
business or if you are the child in the
situation of a family business you have
to deeply understand that when both of
you are done and finished
nobody's gonna count how many zeros they
have in the bank account they're gonna
count how many hearts and vibes and
loves are in the system
my dad and my brother and I were capable
of doing was loving each other just a
little bit more than the business making
some more money or the ego or
insecurities scratches that we needed in
the dynamic of our relationships if
there's anything that this film could
get across to you I hope it is that at
the end of the day on that last breath
ask yourself what you're gonna be really
thinking about
you